yeah welcome to this video and we're
going to play to blitz games here
something different three plus one is
the time control and playing curtains
international master Greg Shahada not
started butchering this pronunciation
terribly two games of three plus one so
he's got a YouTube channel as well of
course if you check my video here the
description I'm going to link to it so
two quick blitz games that he will also
do commentary on yeah the good old Roy
Lopez main line I'm going to play my my
outline you that I want to ditch but ok
what can you do it is not the greatest
line ever but at least I have my have a
ton of experience with it let's see how
it's doing them look p-8a very closed
position that's usually not online when
I get into huge time pressure because
plate is so often it's ridiculous
especially considering that it's not
that great but ok what can you do yeah
ok i'm going to close this which is a
debatable decision but I played it like
that all of the time don't mind that ok
it's going to try for UK 7 but i have
look be 72 to stop that at least Im I'm
quick iam
no they can go get one ok so I can take
a 9 p-7 is not really that great let's
see ok let's start with that maybe after
rupee 7 have to chain with the night the
night on b7 is not a very great piece
but what can you do this is not the the
best possible I'll in the way as I'm
perfectly aware but I have not yet
replaced that with something better so
I'm playing it anyway I came but it's
not doing much against my Ruca a plan
which is kind of nice meaning that i'm
not in a huge issue on the FR and huge
problem yeah i get this get this traded
and this normally means that i'm not in
huge trouble I'm okay
okay it's not a big issue some Queen a
aight i guess and my plane is Bishop d8
Queen a 6 Bishop b6 training this bishop
yeah it's a decent position now and I'm
huge among o is doing a self pen which
is not a big problem admittedly okay
that's what does he wanted to do you
really want to go here maybe ok I have
to move this night anyway it's
completely useless on b7 Queen a six or
a five I can always go Quinn b7
yeah I guess queen bee seven should be
okay or not what is he doing but should
be 60 well ok it's not threatening much
maybe Queen here but Quincy seven I
always have queen bee seven there's no
big problem there we should be six maybe
okay okay going to regroup getting in
night f7 Bishop d8 after all yeah what's
idea can be to sacrifice on c4 maybe
he's trying to go for that not sure if
he will manage at the end but it is an
interesting idea to get this in okay so
I don't mind that trade very much um
queen d 8 he probably won't trade right
okay i can get the king high morning
king up to e7
oh I have got about that idea it's not
not decisive but I feel simply forgot
that you can go with them okay so how do
i do that Queen to a ada I'd like to get
the strain it this-this-this some peace
sacrifice idea is very valid but my king
is near it is near them near the porn so
I don't don't think it is some such a
huge problem check now I'm have
protected that and now the the grand
scale idea comes into plan f5 this is
kind of what black hopes falling after
all this shuffling to get it f5 and
ultimately get a get an endgame out of
that that she can do something with ok
for mMmmm I for it's not what I wanted
to do ok I can't do it it's not not bad
I know that this looks very close but
believe it or not I have an idea in this
position and we're going to see it maybe
if it's mentioned I have played this
quite a lot and I have an idea I am idea
is to sacrifice on d5 and I want to
sacrifice the bishop so I'm really
playing for something even if you don't
believe me so if i take now ok i'm going
to risk that there is some some point of
some some degree of risk to that but i
have played a number of games with that
s set and very often the compensation is
there yeah before I sound difficult to
keep now this line it keeps scoring for
me this is the weird thing ok I cannot
have yet protected it's not really a
great line I might be five maybe I
thought yet might be five in this
position
white exam yeah this is this was the
kind of kind of game that you want to
play with this line kind of soaking up
the pressure and at the end do something
in the end game it's a it's not really
that great but yeah it has it has its
points ok we're going to rematch him
that was a matter of it was a good game
was interesting game so I'm going to do
the rematch and see if he can level the
score this was definitely a position
that aim startling you a bit better than
him let's see what we can do here I
don't even know what he's playing I was
playing I I think he plays the NIMS oh
and the Bogle right ah I remember some
games that he had in them in the bogo
even lines that have featured in my book
so let's do them classical nims oh and
see what what we can get here this is a
very sound line okay so Bishop boys
probably and what I know at the moment
that's not on so let's just in
centralized 194 maybe no i don't know i
would like to play night be five to six
but whenever I move the night there's
Bishop before hitting and my queen s
kind of no squares quite funny yeah this
is a very sound position for black again
even I mean if he doesn't find anything
better he can just take C 3 hey rook c8
or works the aid immediately yeah this
is someone a more ambitious way to do it
so nighty for Bishop if Roy I was
thinking night b5 might be an idea
trying to ask like if this is a good
piece configuration wait can you take on
f2 for Bishop
maybe you can do that I have fruit d3 ok
but McQueen is really out of skoo sort
of squares yeah here was thinking not
deform asking black what what he is
doing with his bishop the bishop has no
square and the night on c5 also has no
square so I don't know not sure how
harmonious this really is it black
should be kind of okay but maybe his
pieces are not harmoniously placed a
three is just a threat of winning the
bishop how is he fighting that then this
night cannot move on c5 and that looks
that looks bad 'if I've maybeee 5v5
night f5 night x f2 for Bishop before
this is becky very rocky business but
maybe a 59 f 59 f 2 95 for night h6 and
checkmate I am this is a cool move I'm
still not convinced if I go 94 now am I
not covering everything here and killing
him what does this move then 9594 I'm
just winning a piece then and I attack
b7 and this distance this is doing it
right what is he doing now
meydan h7 I don't see a move I mean f5
or GC I take b-cell probably and then or
just have to i take f2 f2 is stronger to
take just an opening opening disaster I
somewhat tango these pieces a little bit
here I don't see a move yeah which is 16
yeah what do i do now i just take G to
write an F to write the system must be
must be the most precise way to do it I
think check yeah we get the check but I
can go to g1 simply ok 94 for the trade
or yeah i mean if i go to f3 na trade
that straight stuff a map is up oops is
not taking ok i can take c5 now i can
involve txt file Bishop f4 now where's
your queen going to h5 maybe man but
thats its ok right or just neither 393
simpler um h3 intending g-form
and that's it for the lady check it
resign yeah once by check yeah that was
a that was a bad bad opening somehow I
don't really know what happened there
gay rights old man you crushed me AB
sometimes it happens that way he's
actually very very good blitz player and
mostly is higher rated than me but jab
it somehow didn't didn't work out well
here this some this opening position was
some wasn't any good I think here black
is in trouble I mean what-what to see
supposed to do maybe night back to her
six that's not a move that comes very
naturally to you and even that is good
for white probably now that it's a funny
line here yeah somehow it didn't I mean
I don't know I don't know what went went
wrong there maybe maybe black really
should simply take their or play rook c8
or something like that this must be a
normal position yet black black is kind
of in normal shape maybe just take it
just take it rook c8 avoid this kind of
tangling situations and trying to play
for the for the quick development then
then it should be two totally alright
for like and somehow this this gets this
gets tricky are the confluence to take
on f2 hmm huh interesting he played this
one first I'm sorry that was stupid once
to take their yeah this was in line that
I have mentioned actually because takes
Bishop takes is kind of funny I have
this one but I can also play this kind
of similar to the game and again I'm
threatening made and kind of it's kind
of awkward ya somethin somethin went I
went terribly terribly wrong there yeah
I came this was I was funny um can I
I actually briefly come up with them let
me see if I can get them the game before
that briefly into another this let's
have a look down and I'm going to switch
the board we agreed to first play the
two games and then then only then
analyze them simply that we have a flow
in those games and then this is very
typical this position where why it is
always a bit better but um I don't know
when I could I always feel that if I get
rooks traded if I have a pure position
like that with with all the minor pieces
and the Queen's it's not that a big a
deal I mostly just kept things going it
didn't do anything rash I could play at
five maybe at some point but I believe
in just keeping things here this is
really very very typical procedure the
the big point was i mean this is this is
equal of course nothing nothing
happening yeah but the problem in this
position was that I had exactly this end
game countless times really and I simply
could play the the next phase of the
game very quickly because I simply knew
a plan and I could follow that plan I
was setting it up the whole time you're
getting the king override was it was a
very straightforward planner now this
sacrifice which is probably not winning
or anything but it is very difficult for
why to defend if you have no time on the
clock and if the other guy is kind of
having yeah he simply expects that
happens and so on and now it gets very
tricky yeah the computer says that
probably Bishop before I still drawing
but it looks difficult and here I'm
Winningham this is a terrible position
to defend with no time on the clock
clock it's really a really a problem
I think the most problems black has in
this in this general line is some when
when they keep more pieces on the board
a very nice way was how grandma's
Freezone I'd were played against me he
played before then C 4 and a 5 he just
closed the queenside completely and then
crushed me on the Kings side this made
me give up this line I mean at least in
serious chest and a bit scam okay I can
do it from time to time but it's not
very attractive okay i hope you enjoyed
it it was a was fun let's um don't
forget that you should check Greg's
version he was probably not very
thrilled but it's always good to see
both sides of it okay well thanks for
watching